I was driving down La Cienega here in LA
yesterday and I saw this billboard and I
tweeted it out because I could not
believe it let's take a look okay who's
in the middle of LA like the heart of LA
to all our atheist friends thank God you
are wrong Answers in Genesis dot org now
I tweeted it out and I tagged you and
you retweeted it and then a zillion
people retweeted it and then I started
doing a little more research on it turns
out this is not just in LA this thing
there is a massive digital billboard for
it in Times Square right now
okay there's obviously no audio there
because it's a digital billboard in the
middle of Times Square so the guy who
created this thing is Ken Ham and you
may know Ken Ham because he is the guy
that started the Creation Museum in
Kentucky
what's the Creation Museum well we've
got a picture from there - yeah that's
what appears to be a caveman or a cave
boy and he's playing with a dinosaur
enjoying the smell from yeah this is the
dinosaur fart exhibit is what you're
looking at there okay so we got a lot
here to work with now just first off
let's just look at the Billboard for a
second it actually struck me as
offensive it's really hard to offend me
I'm a comedian I believe in free speech
the guy can do whatever he wants but I
just kept thinking as I was watching
that if you had said hey Jews hey
Muslims thank God you are wrong people
would be up in arms but it seems to me
you're still allowed to attack atheist I
think that I think fundamentally and I
could be wrong about this but that
billboard was a direct response to an
atheist movement billboard that was all
also posted I can't remember what the
atheist movement billboard said but it
was something about being inclusive and
you know atheism is not horrible
and then this response came up that was
I think tongue-in-cheek I mean it's
obviously tongue-in-cheek but it's it's
like it's sharp and biting but also kind
of kind of just like all of my you know
Christian friends in Texas they're so
kind yeah exactly and so uh but I don't
know I mean it doesn't offend me maybe
it's because I'm just so cynical about
it at this point and I've developed such
a thick skin but yeah I mean really
having her free speech right okay so I'm
not saying that he can't do it I'm
really I'm not he could do whatever you
want say whatever you want but really
had it been oh hey Jews hey Muslims
thank God you're wrong I you know what
do people be gone by the twinge of that
every time I see any religious
advertisement and any but to my mind it
simply proves how misguided organized
religion is to begin with yeah because
if you believe if you genuinely believe
that there is an all no
all-powerful deity that created the
world and is so ego driven that it needs
everybody to speak its name in the right
way in order for it to grant them
whatever they think they're going to be
granted does it really need a marketing
department and that's mean I seems very
insecure that that's a very good point I
think what this billboard really goes to
show is how incredibly threatened Ken
Ham feels okay by this new kind of
organized we're starting to see more
organization within the atheist movement
and so when you have organizations like
American atheists or like the Richard
Dawkins foundation the Freedom From
Religion Foundation whatever and they
actually are doing kind of billboards of
their own or they're starting to get
people together to get out the message
and all the sudden Ken Ham says oh [ __ ]
yeah you know are people gonna buy into
this I got to do something about it
that shows that he he thinks that this
is a legitimate movement and he thinks
that that it's got power yeah so are
atheists actually coming out of the
closet now so to speak we last time you
were on the show we did a thing about
how Barney Frank who was openly gay in
Congress for 25 years he had to wait or
seemingly had to wait until he retired
to finally announce that he was an
atheist so is there an actual movement
and do they see it as a threat I I think
it's starting to happen I think the
Internet in many ways has freed up
people to express their true selves in
ways that they couldn't before people
with odd fetishes people with outside of
the mainstream religious beliefs or lack
of religious beliefs people who have had
thoughts that that made them feel
entirely isolated and alone
in a world that presented religion
particularly our nation presented
religion as the norm and a very
particular puritanical kind of religion
as the norm found out that they were not
alone in the world and they immediately
begin communicating and and wanting to
organize and get together and tweet up
as to work yeah we got worried but I
think one of the fundamental issues with
with the
a conversation about there being an
atheist movement is that at its core
atheism is a lack of belief in a higher
power so I always try to make the
distinction when I talk to people about
my own atheism that it's not that I
believe there is no God it's that I
simply don't believe in a God and when
you have a lot of different people who
simply don't believe that there's a
higher power that exists there's nothing
fundamental banding them together
there's no there's no tenets of atheism
there's no mantra there's no church that
we go to and so because of that talking
about an atheist movement I think makes
more sense in in when we reference maybe
a secular movement a group of
individuals who understand that we want
to protect the First Amendment that we
want to keep church and state separate
that we want to make sure that religious
interests aren't aren't impeding on our
own rights as individuals and fringing
on our own rights and that you know a
secular nation from a governing
perspective is a nation that we need to
uphold it's not really about getting an
atheist agenda so here's how difficult
it is for us to fondler I actually
disagree oh the other way on it I don't
it's not that I don't believe in a God I
believe there is no God I believe that
all of that is goofy superstitious
mythology and that that people do
believe it is baffling to me and part of
the difficulty we have is that the you
know the democracy as we practice it
comes and and more importantly
capitalism as we practice it comes out
of a feudal society and the feudal
society that comes out of was a
religious feudal society where the the
leaders were anointed by God and we have
not fully evolved beyond that as a
nation we still require our certainly on
the right we require they require the
their candidates to say God told me to
run and on the left they require their
candidates to still say I believe in God
say I get
I get Bible verses on my blackberry
every morning exactly there's this sort
of nod toward religion in the the
fundamental actions of our democracy as
it stands right now our political
process yeah and I think that we do have
to be active as atheists and as a
secular community to make certain that
we continue to move farther and farther
away from feudalism not back toward it
okay so so final thought on this then
how do you if you have to atheists here
who sort of believe in a slightly
different version of what that means to
you personally how do you gin up the
base then because if everything because
it's so easy to do for the religious
people right and it's so easy to do for
the die-hard partisan hacks on both
sides how do you gin up a base of
rational they're very secular people
they're atheist who don't think we
should
there are many atheists who think that
this is not a movement and this is not a
group of people that should be banded
together there are other atheists who do
think that there should I just I just
spoke last weekend at the CFI conference
or to see if I summit into Gitmo could
do okay I spoke earlier this year at
American atheist and there are you know
humanist societies freethinker societies
skeptic societies where I often visit
and it takes all kinds and so I think
fundamentally again if you want to rally
a base and you want to have an organized
movement that movement needs to be a
political movement it's not gonna be a
religious movement because there's a
lack of religion here that's fundamental
to being an atheist yeah Dylan bring
this thing home I think if you want to
to support the idea of secular society
in a secular nation the way to do it is
by supporting the sciences by supporting
education by supporting anything that
promote the arts supporting anything
that promotes free thinking and critical
thinking and the expansion of the
intellect and the money hey guys the
Rubin reports brought to you by Cooper
comm they have up to 75% off pet treats
choose toys and more and if you use code
RR you can get another 20% that's a lot
of percentage right there I can't do
that kind of math the link is right down
below
Cooper comm code RR